rolling here we go hey what's up
everybody it's Chris right occur what
happened to the coins I already gave you
and I kind of don't adhere to
international pick laws this is Amanda
you know how awkward I am on dates what
if I throw up in her mouth because I'm
so nervous my name is linda VAR c i'm
seeing myself in this outfit I feel
super fly when I wear heels it's Mallory
oh hey it's Mallory looking forward to
Monday baby
I'm Matt bell aside this ice cream shops
at Hot Topic Q and your baby there's a
20% chance I might have sex tonight
this is Justin okay I blew it up tonight
in my way
I feel like a king I'm Zack Evans no you
ever play operation I was benched for a
Golden Retriever named buddy one of my
favorite projects was definitely
straight tested series working on that
was one of my first kind of hosting gigs
it's so much fun turns out short-term
memory isn't that reliable yeah some of
those people talk to you and then one
minute later couldn't remember what
color sweater D was yes my favorite
videos while I was at BuzzFeed probably
were any of the sketches I did with
Quinta and Justin we all came in
together and that was just such a fun
time making whatever we kind of thought
was funny
[Music]
don't take this enhance the bestop best
what makes it the best you are a monster
hey lady do you like Disneyland answer
the question my favorite BuzzFeed videos
that I made but probably the road
trailers they were just a lot of fun and
they're very special yo you excited - hi
khlo Jolla tomorrow
sounds like a sausage fest dude I'm not
going almost there chicks I was a pro
really super behind
there's no coupon friendship zone that's
not yesterday
so we'll get in there and kick Hojo's
greatness friendship and the 75 inch
Tito halter TV probably the most epic
video that I was in was when my friends
at BuzzFeed surprised me with Daniel
Radcliffe that was the most amazing and
scariest moment of my life because I
thought a ghost was coming after me but
it was actually Daniel Radcliffe my
favorite BuzzFeed videos well I did
whine about it when I worked in New York
and I was getting drunk at my desk every
week so it's hard to be back taking off
pants at the end of the day is a [ __ ]
nightmare see and it's like opening up a
hot sweaty ham that's been sitting in
the Sun all day and watching it slide
out of its wet plastic wrapper one of my
favorite videos that I was involved in
was what happens when the lights go out
we're gonna die it it's also just a fun
video that was loosely based on an
experience that I had in college where
we didn't pay our electric bill and once
she made her way into the bathroom
that's what she turned on the light and
found her husband's hey my favorite
BuzzFeed videos that I was involved in
would definitely be the women answer
questions men are afraid to ask video I
helped edit that video and I really
loved being in it having a period
externally having to like look like this
at work and inside your like I also
really loved the two videos I made perks
of having an extrovert best friend and
perks are having an introvert best
friend because my best friend and I are
an extrovert and introvert
currently I am a producer and host with
awesomeness TV I wrote a book called
everything it's awful and other
observations I've been out of BuzzFeed
for a year I've made a channel of my own
I work currently at the Walt Disney
Company on managing a team of really
talented folks to create really cool
digital content and touch people's lives
in a very magical way since I left
BuzzFeed I booked an episode of Arrested
develop
as an actor I booked that with Justin I
will be co-starring in an episode of
Arrested Development next season whole
experience was just surreal I started a
podcast and I make videos on my own I
was one of the correspondents on
election night with Univision and
although I did cry on camera it was a
really great experience
I mean it was a strange day I have a
short film that's been making us round
through the festivals called last night
was a mistake I got my MFA in
screenwriting from the University of
Southern California worked my butt off
and I'm really proud of myself I also
went to buffer festivals with Chantal
Houston we had a video that we made at
BuzzFeed that we entered into the
festival and it won an award it won
excellence and inspiration so I guess
I'm an award-winning inspirer I've also
done some work at the Sacramento Kings I
did some snapchat content for them my
day-to-day involves a lot of going
around town in Hollywood and having
meetings where they give you a tiny
water bottle and they learn about your
life and trying to sell some shows now
we sold one of them and I'm writing it
right now with my good friend and
writing partner sterling brim I'm also
starting my own channel called girl ship
TV it's a channel that was made by queer
women for queer women I also have been
back with BuzzFeed I've been directing a
new face book watch show for them
starring Quinta that's been so much fun
it's been really cool to be back I'm
also gonna appear in a new unsolved
spin-off with Bryan Bergara
about sports conspiracies so looking
forward to that as well I got engaged
that's right everyone wants to see the
ring that's Kevin if you remember us in
some relationship videos we are going to
be starting a YouTube channel dedicated
to our trials and tribulations and just
like our journey to being married I also
have plans to return for a very beloved
franchise over a BuzzFeed it's chicken
watch I'm coming back to do chicken
watch because Keith asked me to and I
loved it she can watch 2k15 we're gonna
find the best rotisserie chicken and any
grocery store chain in Los Angeles I
miss you guys I miss everyone at
BuzzFeed
hope everyone's doing well I'm just
excited to be back here with you guys
mommy's gonna take those memories and I
always look back onto those videos and
say those were a good day I just want to
say thanks for all the viewers out there
who watched BuzzFeed I am still a huge
fan got love for the Busbee family thank
you for having me and you'll be seeing
me you'll be seeing me around oh you'll
be seeing me around it's just a very
creative community hey good tell Quinta
to text me back also - Keith - like cool
it I'm texting me back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]